Paxos is a really fundamental algorithm
in distributed systems it was invented
over a decade ago by Leslie Lamport who
is very famous one day Turing Award
which is like their computer science
equivalent to the Nobel Prize and he's
had tons of contributions and this is
really one of the most important ones
that he did during his time doing
research it's forgetting computers who
can talk to each other to agree on
something
so computers just like your computer at
home they sometimes fail sometimes the
network gets cut off and yet we still
need to have a reliable system over that
so for example with your bank if you
transferred money from one person to
another and then the money kind of went
out your account but never arrived at
the other account because a computer
somewhere had failed you won't be very
happy about it so we need to be able to
reliably reach agreement between
machines even though they're silly and
they fail and they break and networks
fail Paxos has two kind of main phases
and the key thing to paxos is in each of
these phases you have to have the
majority of nodes coming to an agreement
before we can move on so that means in a
system of five nodes you need three
nodes to be an agreement before we can
move on so it's democracy work yeah
absolutely and it's super useful because
it means that if some of the nodes are
down you just carry on without them and
that's absolutely fine when they come
back up if they come back up we can help
them along and tell them about what
happened say you're a client for example
you're a person who wants to get a lock
and it's super important in the system
that only one person can ever get this
lock we might have a system here of five
nodes and we might have a client over
here it's called our Alice and she
wishes to procure some super useful lock
and we have to make sure that only one
person can ever have this lock so she
that's a nice note hey can you get hold
of this lock for me in this system we
have five nodes and so we need three of
them at each stage to agree before we
can move on and there are two main
stages there's the promise stage
there's the commit stage the notes going
to generate a unique ID
we'll say their ideas 13 and they're
going to contact every other node and
say hey guys I want to make some
progress on this will you agree to let
me do that and they say yeah that's
absolutely fine and they remember that
they've agreed so I'll call it P for
promise that they will remember that
they promise that 13 would be the node
that's in charge of getting stuff done
okay and they're all happily no failures
at the moment they all happily agreed
and so we can move on to the next stage
in the next stage node 3 on behalf of
alice is gonna contact everybody and say
hey everybody can you commit ID 13 the
fact that let's say alice is the person
who's gonna have the lock and all of
these guys remember that it's Alice I'll
just write a little a for each of them
who has it they also remember that it
was 13 what's the ID and they will
respond and say okay and now no three
can say Alice there you go you have a
lock you can go on do it was you want to
do and regardless of what happens in
this system in terms of failures we'll
never give anybody else that lock okay
that's entirely yours
so so just give an example of this lock
is maybe access to her account or if it
were banking or something yeah yeah it
could be access to an account it could
be for example the ability to write to a
file so often in code we have regions of
code where we want to ensure that only
one machine person only one person is
ever executing that so maybe they're
editing a file and you don't want
multiple people trying to do this and
the other thing is like with a bank
account you might want to kind of have
the lock you know I'm the only person
who can change this amount right now and
then when you finished give that up lock
so super useful and they're really kind
of widely used abstraction so a simple
thing like this can then be used loads
within systems so you know here Alice is
a person but often Alice would be you
know a device operating on behalf of the
person let's have a look at what happens
if one of these machines was to fail for
example actually let's make it worse
let's make two machines fail so here
comes
she wants to procure this lock she talks
to node 5
it's like and says hey can you get this
lock for me so node 5 is gonna send out
a message to everyone saying and say
their idea is 15 well you promised to
let me in with ID 15 these guys will
respond and it will respond to itself
saying that's okay you can go ahead with
that and they'll remember they promised
15 now this is a system of five nodes
and as I said we need a majority and we
have a majority here because we've got
node 1 node 4 and node 5 that's three
notes so despite the fact these two
nodes a completely offline that's fine
and we can carry on five can then send
out a message to everyone again saying
can you commit the fact to that 15 and
it's gonna be Alice and then all of
these guys will remember Alice who got
the book with ID 15 now in the future
these nodes might come back up hopefully
you know sent for an engineer and
they've come fix the problem for you and
nodes 2 & 3 that have recovered don't
know anything about what's going on so
maybe someone else comes along sista -
hey I'm Bob and I would like that block
please no 2 is gonna send a message to
everyone saying I would like to be in
charge
12 and each of these from before have
remembered the last person that they
promised to Pat ID 15 once you've made a
promise you can only break your promise
to someone with a higher ID than the ID
that you promised - so these numbers go
up and up over time so in this case 12
is smaller than 15 so these guys are
gonna say no actually 3 will say yes
because they don't know what's going on
with the system beforehand so they'll
say 12 and everyone else is gonna say ok
so in this case number 2 is gonna have
another go try again and they're going
to generate a new ID and they're going
to make sure that their ID is bigger
than any of the ideas that they saw
earlier so say
you're 22 now I'll try not say to over
and hey but 22 can I be in charge of
what's going on
I'm 22 is higher than 15 so they're
actually you're going to come back and
say yeah that's okay but the really
important stage here is that if they
have committed a value before when they
say okay
they'll include what the value was so in
this case it was notes 1 4 & 3 and when
they say okay
they will also say that previously it
was agreed that Alice had the lock with
ID 15th and so that would be this guy
this guy in this guy will say that so
he's out Alice stuffed at this point is
she stuffed no not quite yet
well it's Bob that's got the problem
here because it's Bob that won't be able
to get this so even though ii was trying
to operate on box behalf and get this
lock bob the two has just found out that
actually alice had already been agreed
and so what two will do is instead of
sending out a commit for Bob to is
actually going to send that one commit
with Alice to everybody and say commit
it's number which was 22 Alice okay you
throw me day so the the idea of paxos is
that in the end everyone needs to find
out about what happened so in this
example two and five one aware of what
happened and in as a side effect of to
trying to do something which was
conflicting twos actually found out
about what happened and they've told
everybody so 5 after they recovered
didn't have a clue what was going on and
now they know actually it was Alice that
has got the lock so by going through
that extra stage before you commit
anything we ensured that Bob couldn't
have got that lock so the thing about
having the higher ID was just him trying
it on was it yeah so you if it hadn't
have been committed if it had just been
promised would he have got locked then
because he's got a higher ID or is that
if it had just been promised he would
have been able to yeah so what you
basically do is you once you get a
promise from everybody if nobody has
told you that any
it's been committed you're free to
choose whatever way you want to commit
however if things have gone wrong for
example maybe the note that was actually
trying to do the commit might have
failed midway through you might end up
getting one person telling you Alice had
it another person was saying both had it
another person saying Charlie had it and
the importance of the IDs here is that
whoever has the highest ID with it
that's the one that you then disseminate
everybody in say charlie is the one who
has the lock let's have a look at what a
failure
midway through might actually look like
this is Note 3 and we've got our friend
Alice still trying to get her get her
lock in the system so as before no three
is gonna ask everyone to price with our
ID which will say 13 and everyone will
remember that they promised 13 I was
born to say it was ok and then 3 my
message these guys and say commit for
Alice in 13 and then no three might fail
we have to work out what do we do
did Alice ever get that lock did I was
not get my lock so the message was sent
to notes 1 and 2 before 3 failed so
these guys are going to agree and send
back but these messages matter because
333 has unfortunately failed so we have
to kind of look at this and work out
what to do about this so in the future
someone else might come along and try to
get this lock and if say this is full
trying to do this when they're gonna
send out their promise and they're gonna
try and send out their commit and when
they do this they're gonna find out that
people have already committed Alice and
therefore they won't give it away again
instead they'll just how everybody but
it was Alice who was successful would
there be a majority there though if
there are four nodes and two of them the
interesting thing about majorities is if
you have say sf5 notes and you need 3/4
majority any majorities will always
overlap so if you ask and you get a
majority and just one of them says this
thing happened
that there could be a majority that
exists where that happened so just one
person saying something happened is
enough I see because it's committed it
must have been a majority at some point
yeah absolutely okay and then does I
always have to find out by those three
stars so paxos itself is just kind of a
really kind of basic right there and you
build systems on top of it so it's up to
the system and usually what would happen
in this scenario is a lished with trying
asking someone else can you do this for
me and find out that it was successful
so basically this is a yeah you might
implement in various ways is that what
to say yeah yeah absolutely and the big
thing as well is this is just agreement
over a single value but in practice we
want to reach agreement over many values
we want the value to change over time
you know you want Alice to be able to
get a lock and then return the lock and
because of that what we use is something
called multi Paxos which is like this
but multiple times basically and the
really interesting insight here is that
this took two stages to kind of
round-trip times across the network but
the first stage when we were sending out
these promise messages none it didn't
matter that it was Alice or Bob it
didn't matter what was going on so what
we can do is we can do this first stage
before any requests are even there and
by doing that when Alice comes along if
the nodes already done the first stage
it's just one round-trip time obviously
they're putting in a bit of groundwork
before anyone even asks so if I the user
here and they wanted something would you
be alright with that yeah basically so
when we when we did this for the first
time there was no resolution there was
no kind of thing that said it was Alice
when we did that first round so they can
basically do that in advance before they
even know and then when someone comes
along and asked for it than me then they
can get it but the restriction that
would be at the moment Alice could ask
anybody and they could do it and it
would take two kind of phases or two
round-trip times if you if three kind of
did their preparation work first then
Alice would only be able to go to three
but if they did go to three then it
would just take one round-trip time
when we do this bit of work we call this
kind of electing a leader so you'll
basically say to one machine you're in
charge so you can pretty much any
setting and you can say you're gonna be
the leader you're gonna be in charge and
that could be one of the people one of
their machines one of the servers in the
cloud and then you send all the requests
so that one and then they distribute it
like this well it's probably one of the
most common places this is used I would
actually say this example is probably a
really good example of where it's used
so in big distributed systems it's
really important to have this idea of
locks so this idea that only one person
can be doing certain things at a time we
like to think that systems are really
parallel and we have lots of things
going on at once but at some point
usually we we need to say actually only
one person is allowed to edit a file at
the time only one person is allowed to
permission to access this key at that
time so locks in just for your system is
a really good example of where you might
where you might mean something like this
problem is that any of these connections
have these are all using HTTP then
there's no way for the browser to verify
that the data that's coming back here